alrighty i'm back for another one first
of all again guys thanks for the
continued support on the videos and the
subscribers if you get me to 10 000
maybe i'll just quit my job already
before i even start doing it and then
you know the only downside of that is i
can stop click baiting the the name of
my company and all of my videos but you
know is what it is uh today we're gonna
be covering
aws aurora which is another new sequel
type of database i figure it kind of
fits in nicely since we just spoke about
spanner so yeah let's go over that and i
think it makes for a pretty interesting
concept it applies some of the stuff
that we've learned in the past so let's
go ahead and do a deep dive
okay so aurora what is it well like i
mentioned aurora is another type of
these new sql databases which basically
means it's got a sql interface but a
much different approach to actually
implementing sql on a cloud computing or
distributed level scale
than you know typical mysql or postgres
it's apparently boasting a 35 or not 35
percent but rather 35 times improvement
over traditional sql solutions and as a
result i think it's worth taking a dive
into how that actually goes ahead and
works
okay so what is the traditional rdbms
design
basically and i've mentioned this in the
past especially on the time series video
this was the most relevant especially
for b-tree-based solutions
most databases look something like this
where we have this b tree on the disk
and then we have this layer of memory so
obviously that's going to be smaller and
that is called a page cache so the point
of the page cache is to load in relevant
parts of the b tree that are either
being accessed frequently for reads or
if you know there's a right and we have
to modify a part of the b tree what
first happens is the b tree is loaded
into memory that page is going to go
ahead and be modified
and then a change is going to be written
into the write ahead log basically
saying okay we've made this change right
here now it's going to be persistent by
virtue of being in that right ahead log
you know it's not necessarily important
that we write the page back to disk just
yet because it's in the right ahead log
if things were to crash we could just go
ahead and use that right ahead log to
recover from that and make sure that
everything was in disk as it's supposed
to be so this way is kind of how we can
buffer some of those rights to memory
but whatever that's a kind of irrelevant
for now
the point is though the change that
aurora makes is the following so it
actually decouples the memory and that
disk into two different servers so we
have now is we have a server basically
acting solely as the page cache and then
we have a server that is going to be
just acting as the actual storage itself
the thing to note here is that it
generally takes too long to send an
entire modified page from the page cache
over network to the disk why would we be
sending a modified page from the page
cache to the disk well every single time
we make a write
so typically pages are about eight
kilobytes and that's not really feasible
here so what aurora has instead uh
decided to do is instead of going ahead
and sending back the whole page it's
just going to send the corresponding
right uh right ahead log entry and as a
result that right ahead log entry is
going onto the disk and now things are
going to be persistent the disk can kind
of in the background go ahead and make
those updates locally but it doesn't
really have to do it in any timely
fashion as long as things are in the
right ahead log a write is considered
persistent
another nice thing about this is that it
means that both disk and memory can be
replicated and scaled independently so
we're going to see how that would
actually go ahead and happen
in terms of replication of storage so
this is kind of what we would do for the
disk typically what happens is we have
you know a memory server so this is kind
of like our
database server which i'll call the
database server the cache server and
then we also have something called a
protection group so in aurora a
protection group is a group of six disk
servers which comprise three
availability zones which means different
data centers and the reason you do this
is obviously so that if one of those
availability zones goes down you still
have replicated data hopefully at least
on the other two
so we're going to see now how writes
actually go ahead and work because
they're actually pretty interesting in
this type of system
so what does a write do it basically
requires a quorum of nodes in order for
this to work
so the database node is going to receive
a write that's on the caching layer and
it's going to basically go ahead and say
okay i have my entry from the right
ahead log i'm going to go ahead and send
that to all six of those nodes in the
protection group and once i get positive
responses out of four of them i'm going
to say this right is committed so that's
basically all it comes down to and then
like i mentioned this ensures high
availability if one of those zones goes
down
in terms of reads they actually don't
need to use a quorum we'll see where
quorum reads come in a little bit but
for now just in terms of getting strong
consistent reads out of that database
node it's actually pretty easy
all the database light air has to do or
the caching layer has to go ahead and
take the read request look at its log
which we know is up to date because as
of now it's kind of the the single
caching layer
it says i have an up to date log i know
the current position of the log so i'm
going to now check out all of these
other
replica storage nodes find the one that
is up to date as of the point of this
log and go ahead and make a read of that
in that sense we can actually get
strongly consistent reads out of this
kind of leader
database caching mode
okay additionally you can actually
replicate the caching layer itself like
i said we can scale these replicas
independently of one another the
protection group storage is scaled to
six nodes and then the caching layer
itself can be scaled i believe up to
actually 15 nodes
but keep in mind that only one of them
can be making rights the rest are
actually going to be read only in kind
of like a primary backup replication
schema so basically what happens is as
that main leader cash gets rights it's
going to go ahead and asynchronously
replicate its right ahead log over to
all of those other read-only replicas
and then the read-only replicas can go
ahead and use their local copy of the
write ahead log in order to serve read
requests by using the same process that
i just mentioned namely check the write
ahead log see what the current position
is issue a request to one of the storage
replicas that is up to date as of that
right ahead log
the thing to note though is that since
the write ahead log is being
asynchronously propagated from the main
cache replica to the other cache
replicas
all of those
logs are going to be a little bit out of
date on all of the cash replicas and so
they are going to issue reads that are
going to be eventually consistent namely
they can return stale data generally
speaking though in most applications
it's not a huge deal and if it is a huge
deal you can always just go perform
reads from the actual leader itself
so then why are we doing this quorum
because i mentioned we're doing a quorum
of rights but we're not making quorum
reads and as a result of that we can't
necessarily ensure strongly consistent
reads well actually quorum rights are
very important for ensuring fault
tolerance and ensuring that everything
stays consistent on failures so let's
look at the case of the failure of the
database node so keep in mind or think
of the the following case where a
database node issues a couple of writes
and then it fails before it can issue
the rest of the writes to the rest of
the storage nodes of the protection
group so now we have this inconsistency
where as you can see
out of all of these disk nodes two of
them have different radar log positions
and obviously 101 and 102 couldn't
possibly be committed
so now what's going to happen is that
when the database node goes ahead and
fails
these storage nodes are going to be out
of sync with one another and they're not
going to converge because the the
database node isn't there to kind of
propagate those rights to them
so instead what's going to happen is
this a new node is going to take over is
the database node
and it's going to perform a quorum read
which means it's going to perform
perform a read from four out of the six
replicas so once you read from those
four replicas it doesn't really matter
which ones we get
it is necessarily going to be the case
that you can't get a majority of nodes
with one of those higher values but
instead it's going to be the case that
the highest or basically the quorum read
is going to tell us what the highest
accepted value is out of all of the
nodes there and we're going to see that
100 is the highest committed log value
and as a result of that we can just go
ahead and revert the rest of the writes
that were kind of beyond 100 so the the
101 right and the 102 right get thrown
away
if a storage node were to fail so this
is going to be one of those yellow nodes
in the protection group then we have to
think of the following so i haven't
mentioned this yet but basically every
single
database table in aurora is partitioned
into 10 gigabyte segments and those 10
gigabyte segments are what make up a
protection group
however imagine you have you know a
terabyte large table which means that
you're going to have a 110 gigabyte
segments and you know if multiple users
or multiple you know companies are using
the same aurora servers it means that
you might have a bunch of these 10
gigabyte segments on a single node or a
single server basically and as a result
it's going to be a real pain in the ass
if you have to go ahead and copy over
100 segments
in a sequential manner over the network
from you know one replica to another so
instead what aurora does to go ahead and
mitigate this issue is they kind of take
a consistent hashing approach where you
split up all of those chunks of that
failed server and then you know using
the replicas obviously you're copying
over the chunks to a variety of
different servers in order to actually
parallelize the network i o as opposed
to
sending everything in order and that way
overloading the network so by
parallelizing
these individual failures of storage
nodes are not a huge deal
okay so i know this was a pretty quick
video but in conclusion basically aurora
is another really cool new sql system
and it has big implications in terms of
making relation
relational databases viable again
obviously if you can compete with nosql
performance but then get these type of
guarantees in terms of
you know the validity of your data using
normalization as opposed to
denormalization having these
cross-shared transactions that's
actually super useful
that being said it's probably not going
to be overly useful to know about the
specifics of something like aurora or
spanner in an interview however i
personally think that a this channel is
about going in depth on systems design
and b
if you are able to kind of work
something like an aurora or a spanner
into your systems design conversation it
can really show that you've done your
research and you've done a lot of
significant studying into all of these
different types of storage systems so in
that sense i think it's useful i'll
probably do one more new sql system
known as volt db at some point in the
near future but at this point i'm kind
of going in more of a free form order so
we'll see what i get to next either way
guys i hope you enjoyed the video thanks
again for all the new subscribers and i
look forward to making